- [Voiceover] What I
want to do in this video,
is think a little bit more about
how populations can be regulated.
And broadly speaking, we can think of
the regulation of populations
it two different categories.
There's the regulation
dependent on density,
so density, density dependent
regulation, density dependent.
And then, there's the type of regulation
that isn't dependent on density,
so we could call that density
independent regulation.
Independent, independent regulation.
So first let's think about
density dependent regulation.
Let me draw a little chart
here, to help us visualize that.
So let's say that that
axis is the population.
I'll say P for population.
And let's say this axis is time.
So, T for time.
In previous videos we
talked about a population,
and I like to use the example of rabbits,
how it could grow exponentially.
So if it's just growing a
certain percent every month,
that population will grow exponentially,
but we can't expect that that
will just happen forever,
if rabbits just kept
growing exponentially,
it wouldn't take long for them to
cover the surface of the earth,
and and then fill the universe,
if in some way they weren't
limited by anything.
But we know that they
are limited by things.
And so the environment
only has a certain amount
of carrying capacity, and
we'll think a little bit
about this carrying capacity in a second,
and what's determining
the carrying capacity.
And so as the density of the
rabbits in a certain area
get higher and higher
and higher, well then
the density dependent,
use a different color,
the density dependent
factors start to play,
the density dependent limiting factors.
And what could be some of these
density dependent limiting factors that
keep the population from going
dramatically above the carrying capacity?
Well the most obvious one could be
competition for resources, competition,
competition, for, resources.
And the one that might
come to mind most clearly
is food resources.
So this is actually a picture
of Australia in the mid 1800s.
And they had a bunny population problem.
The rabbits were first introduced
in order to have a little bit of hunting,
but then they reproduced like rabbits.
And it was estimated that at some point
you had over a billion rabbits
that had populated the
country, and that was,
you might say, how cute,
but it was a huge problem.
(stammering) The were
eating all of the farmable,
they were eating crops.
They were eating the grass that
other types of livestock would graze on.
So it was a huge infestation of rabbits.
And so you can imagine one
competition for resources
is just the grass itself.
In this picture you can
see the land is barren.
Maybe this happened because the rabbits
ate all of the vegetation here.
So, competition for resources,
one type of resource
could be food, another type
of resource could be water,
there might only be so much water
to support organisms of a certain kind.
You know here, we often
talk about animals,
but it could be plants,
or it could be bacteria,
it could be all sorts of organisms
that we're talking about.
And if we're talking about plants,
we could think about light.
You could say, well what limits
having an infinite number
of plants in a certain area?
Well, water will limit,
the nutrients in the soil
will limit, but also access to light.
You've seen pictures of a
dense canopy in a rain forest,
and the plants are trying to seek out
whatever gap in the canopy they can find,
so that they can get some
access to that light.
Now there's other examples,
and this wouldn't apply
as much to, say, plants,
but the idea of shelter.
This might apply to humans, or to other
types of animals that maybe
need shelter in order to hide,
or a place to reproduce, or whatever else.
So at some point, if the
population density gets too high
in a certain region, then these things
are going to limit how dense
the population can get,
or frankly just what the
population actually is,
and so that would lead, once again
we talked about this in a previous video,
to this logistic curve right
over here, where we just,
we don't, we just start
approaching the carrying capacity,
and it is possible that you could even
go above the carrying capacity
and then you're at kinda
this very unstable situation,
and then something happens
and you go below it, then you go above it,
and then below it, and
then something like that.
But what are other
density dependent factors
that we could think about?
Well, another thing is,
if you were a predator,
when, say, the rabbits become this dense,
it's much easier to
start to pick them off,
it's much easier to get your lunch.
And so, predatory factors,
or we could say predation, predation.
Once a population gets large
enough and dense enough,
it might be the predators who can say,
hey, we can start, it's way
easier for us to get our lunch.
Now the other thing, it might
be a little less obvious,
but when you have a
high density population,
and there's examples of this
in medieval times in Europe,
and even in modern times
today with human populations,
but this happens with all organisms,
is that when you become
a dense population,
there's more interaction.
There's more contact, there's more
sharing of resources like water, and so
disease and parasites becomes an issue.
So let me write this down,
disease, disease, and parasites
can spread much easier, and
they're much more likely to
start limiting the population.
The thing that always comes
to my mind is the plague
in medieval times, where
it was very easy to spread
from one human to the next, or
frankly from rats to
humans, and whatever else.
Now the other thing, and this is maybe
somewhat related to everything else
we've talked about, is waste accumulation.
So let me write this right over here.
Waste.
If you have a really
high density population,
and the waste is just everywhere,
it could poison the water,
it might poison sources of food,
it might help the spread
of disease and parasites.
And once again, all of
these things help define
what the carrying capacity,
how dense can a population
get in a certain region.
Now you might say, well maybe they don't
have to stay in a region, maybe they can
go and explore other
places, and that's possible,
and that's been the story for
many different types of species.
Lemmings are famous for, when
their population gets dense
in a certain area, groups of them
start just running to start
exploring other areas.
Sometimes running in directions
that are not that good for them.
So all of these are
density dependent factors.
And a lot of these, as
we just talked about,
you could think of them as biotic factors.
They're related to other
living things around.
The density independent
factors tend to be a-biotic.
They tend to be not
related to living things.
So the most common
density independent factor
is natural disasters.
So, natural, natural disaster.
We have a picture here of a forest fire.
The deer population here
might not be in any way
close to their carrying
capacity, but despite that,
the forest fire maybe might
kill off a lot of the deer.
Other natural disasters,
you could have a flood,
you could have a tsunami, you could have
a meteorite coming from outer space.
That happened to the dinosaurs.
To just knock out huge populations.
And so, density independent factors,
you could have the
population growing and it's,
and at just some random point it just,
there's some density independent factor,
there's a forest fire, there's
a flood, or something else.
And then maybe the
population grows from there,
and eventually gets closer
to its carrying capacity,
who knows, but the density
independent factors, once again,
it's not related to where
we are on this curve.
It could happen at any
time, and to some degree
they feel a little bit more random.
Now, with all of this talk
about carrying capacity
and the different density
dependent factors,
you might be thinking well,
what about human beings?
We are for sure a species, and so
the same ideas apply to us.
And so is there a
natural carrying capacity
for the environments that we are in?
And there's a famous philosopher
scientist Thomas Malthus,
and I have a whole video on him, but
he hypothesized that humanity
had a very serious problem.
Because our populations
were growing exponentially,
so this is population, this is time,
and so he said, look, there's just
a natural carrying
capacity for human beings.
And as human beings just
kept growing exponentially,
We would hit that carrying capacity,
and the term for that carrying capacity,
in the case of human beings,
that Thomas Malthus set up,
and there's a whole video on
this, is the Malthusian limit.
And he hypothesized
that once you crossed it
or approached it, there
would be all sorts of crises,
that once you're at
this carrying capacity,
there might not be enough food, and then
there might be a famine,
or we go across it
and then disease spreads a lot more.
And so he was just applying these
ideas of density dependent
factors to human populations
and said hey, this is not going
to be pleasant for humanity.
Now what's been interesting,
is that humanity
has found ways repeatedly, of pushing up
the carrying capacity for us as a species.
We've been able to do it,
frankly through technology.
Frankly finding ways to grow food
in denser and denser ways,
ways to stave off disease,
ways to get rid of waste
and sewage and all of that,
so it's an interesting
philosophical question to say,
is there ever gonna be a point where
human being just hits this Malthusian,
where human society hits
this Malthusian limit,
or are we always going
to be able to fend it off
by just better and better
technology, or maybe even
just regulation of the population itself,
so that we don't, you know,
where we just have whatever,
birth control, or family
planning, or whatever it might be,
so that we are less likely
to hit some eventual limit.